peine à Dieu ma mère adieu tous mes
parents
voilà que je vous quitte au jourduit
pour longtemps cette chanson Jean la
pointe l'avait lui-même chanté dans l'un
de ces rôles au cinéma
d'avoir eu peur de la mort
[Applaudissements]
pour son père mais aussi l'auteur le
chanteur le comédien l'humoriste
du Québec
et du Canada de sa génération un homme
plus grand que nature qui a inspiré des
milliers d'artistes son jus naturaliste
son jeu vrai
ancrer totalement dans la vérité il est
de l'ordre du documentaire
on n'avait jamais vu ça au cinéma
québécois on avait jamais vu ça à la
télévision québécoise c'est une
[Musique]
grande comprendre et de pouvoir exprimer
les émotions de la condition humaine et
c'était ce talent l'autre qu'il avait
c'est un grand imitateur c'est un grand
chanteur c'est un compositeur c'était
vraiment la quintessence de l'artiste un
grand artiste puis je l'ai connu dans la
vie ici c'est à quelqu'un spécial
pour nous Jean Lapointe était souvent un
emmerdeur de pire espèce
c'est avec humour que celui qui a dirigé
la maison dans la pointe à décrit la
générosité du fondateur Jean Lapointe le
résilient le combattant de l'alcoolisme
de tes souffrances pour alléger celle de
tes sœurs et frères d'armes
40 années de dons de soie à ce que tu
appelles à juste titre ta plus grande
fierté ta fondation est ta Maison Jean
Lapointe un modèle pourtant de victime
de l'alcool
vers l'abstinence
genre la pointe un des piliers de la
culture québécoise cet état en emportant
les souvenirs d'une génération de
Québécois ne laissant que ses œuvres à
l'épreuve du temps il s'est Marie-José
paquet
[Musique]
raconte
la même histoire
où tout est gris ou